Republican lawmakers are dismissing the
chances of a government shutdown this
October one month before the midterm
elections now that is despite president
Trump's tweet that he quote would be
willing to shut down the government if
the Democrats do not give us the votes
for border security which includes the
wall Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
Nancy good morning good morning and that
tweet came as a surprise to Republican
leaders who thought they had conveyed to
the president how difficult it would be
for them to secure billions of dollars
in wall funding by October they warned
that a shutdown and immigration fight
one month before the midterm elections
could cost the party time and votes I
certainly don't like playing a shutdown
politics Wisconsin Senator Ron Johnson
was one of several Republicans this
weekend actively discouraging the White
House from courting a shutdown I don't
think it'd be helpful so let's try and
avoid it the shutdown threat was a
presidential attempt at hardball over
his long sought funding for a border
wall but the Senate's Republican leader
Mitch McConnell said Congress may not be
able to get to that until December at
the earliest is the funding of the
border wall going to wait until after
the midterm elections probably and
that's something we do have a
disagreement on McConnell and House
Speaker Paul Ryan met with the president
last week to discuss the fall
legislative agenda and the obstacles to
quick funding of the wall the
president's willing to be patient to
make sure that we get what we need so
that we can get that done because border
security is extremely important but the
president's patience now appears to be
wearing thin though he has backed off
similar threats before if we don't
change it let's have a shutdown will do
a shutdown and it's worth it for our
country the yeas are 71 that time there
was a shutdown but it lasted just a
couple hours and with the midterm
elections looming Republicans are hoping
to avoid a shutdown of any length we're
gonna make sure we keep the government
open but we're gonna get better policies
on immigration the president has already
secured about 1.5 billion dollars in
border security but he wants up to 25
billion to build the wall and Democrats
have signaled that they're open to that
but only if
publicans agree to protect the daka
population those so-called dreamers and
so far anthony congress has been unable
to find a compromise and now the house
is gone for the next five weeks Nancy
Cordes Thank You Nancy